hi guys i'm monica chan and i'm hoodie
katan and today we're going to be
playing glamour's bestie test who do you
think's going to win i think she's going
to win i do too
so me and hida have been best friends
since i was born
we're only a year and a half apart and
you're in eight months i mean you're in
eight months older than her i used to go
around school and protect her because
she's my little sister so like when
people were mean to her i'd be like were
you mean to my sister would you say to
my sister
that is true i was like really shy but
it was like my bossy sister who like was
protective protective and also just like
a really
big badass not much has changed but i've
done a lot of therapies
so i guess that's because of me
that too all right guys round one of do
you even know me let's see do you know
me i think so i don't know okay so
what's my biggest pet peeve
you don't like when i take my hair and
do this well i was going to say
cleanliness like dirty bathrooms
disorderly i guess
so yeah i think that's kind of half a
point
that's a full point i was gonna say when
people don't uh close the toilet seat
when they flush that's like my ultimate
puppy probably number one but you're in
the same category she's hygiene she's
ocd and organization is that a full
point half away it's a full point okay
oh my god it's a full point all right
would i choose no foundation or no
mascara for the rest of my life
definitely you would choose no mess no
foundation sorry
what is my go-to fragrance for date
night
i really thought you'd get this
hold on a second wait wait i want to
know this now is it in violin no
it's a deja vu no
it's a vanilla oh my god it would
definitely if i had to pick one it's
sweet diamond but i always
layer so it's sweet diamond vanilla and
musk that's the combination no
use no
later
what's my biggest fear that is hard no
you know this there's a few that come to
mind okay
i'm sleeping alone at night
no no spiders oh geez
i didn't know that oh my god do you even
know me i have a question do you even
know me
so where would you find me at a party
in the middle dancing
yeah that's true
what's the weirdest cosmetic hack i've
tried
you better know this one oh oh my god
you guys are good with the question
they're all weird no there was one that
was super weird
i mean there's many weird ones but uh
i think when you put cotton in your eyes
no your eyelashes no loop on the face is
primer oh yeah shoot that yeah you did
do that oh my god i can't believe you
don't know me
so how do i calm my nerves
breathing
the way you breathe
you slow down your breath you do box
breathing that's when one of the things
or or you are you're very spiritual
person yeah so i like to i like to say a
prayer whenever i'm stressed it calms me
down do you breathe do you do the
breathing i do box breathing sometimes
but it's nothing i want to say it's the
number one thing okay it's occasional
maybe i didn't get that one i didn't get
that one
that's my phone screensaver you and noor
no oh my gosh she really doesn't know me
you know and chris it's
just just nowhere we have a lot of
phones no it's the only phone i've had
i've had the same screenshot for two
years
[Laughter]
what is the one thing that you do that
annoys me the most
i think the thing that i do probably is
always try to give you advice when you
don't always win it that annoys you the
most
and i can be really bossy about it
sometimes
i was gonna say um making me wait around
for you all the time that's funny
because i feel like i'm always waiting
around for you i'm literally always
waiting around for you
well that's what i was gonna say but i'm
always waiting around for you that's not
true okay who was my celebrity crush
growing up jonathan taylor thomas no
zach morris i was made by the black
forest but i did have a zack morris
poster in my office not too long ago so
i'm surprised you didn't see that i was
the ac slater girl
what is my beverage of choice i used to
like coffee a lot
but it's changed i feel like now it's
water what kind of water
it didn't ask for the specific kind of
water i'd say coconut water is my
favorite
i never see drink coconut water i you
know what we should have her in the neck
questions now because she's definitely
changing i drink it daily do you every
single day i don't see you drinking it
every day i don't think we're actually
best friends
we're just sisters
what's my biggest beauty vice
i feel like i'm a few i don't really i
don't really know the answer to this
either i have a few i mean maybe when
things are not symmetrical like
i feel like it's under eye like when
concealer is not set that really bothers
me a lot i was going to say which is why
i think brow symmetry because you get on
to me about that a lot yeah
for me i really like a really nice clean
under eye
yeah i have mentioned that a lot yeah i
mentioned that a lot what's the most
binge-worthy tv show in my opinion
friends
i mean yes
who would like to play me if they made a
film about me zendaya
really no i would love that but i don't
see the similarities would you cast i
don't know i i feel like i find an indie
actress like that nobody really knows
okay that cat question doesn't count
which beauty trend do i regret following
i mean you messed up your brows pretty
bad that wasn't a trend though that
wasn't intentional
i don't really feel like you follow
trends though you don't she's not a
trend she's not trend driven i love
trends mona doesn't love trends
yeah so she's done some things that she
i guess it was not trendy you just
messed up your brows for no reason
that's true what's my party trick hidden
talent ooh barking like a dog
oh
okay you should do it
[Laughter]
you are you're not gonna bark like a dog
right now come on do it it'll be fine
[Laughter]
what went wrong on my wedding day
everything because um it's only one
thing no oh
the way hold on
my wedding was pretty awesome but no
there was one major thing what was it
come on there was a lot of things in my
face one major thing no i can't answer
this there's too many things for me my
hairstyle is built on me
i i don't know if they built on you or
um
i don't know they didn't show up i think
there was a lot of things
in my opinion okay well yeah all right
question number nine
when i was younger what did i want to be
when i grew up a singer yeah
yeah she but she you had a lot of things
you wanted to do but i really
and also i always like thought you were
going to be president
i did she's like everybody's like she
really likes to like lead um and i was
always like i'll be her vice president
all right so now we're gonna do round
two playing who's who
for sure 100 100
[Music]
i like to take my time
i do my facial massage i like to listen
to an audio book it's my me time
she's just the sweetest
she's the sweetest person probably one
of these people i know oh thank you like
literally probably true yeah
i don't know
you're an artist but you don't have a
steady hand have you seen my eyeliner i
was just thinking
it's definitely her she's so good with
gifts um i think your love language is
gifts like gift giving i like giving
people gifts like i do enjoy it yeah you
can tell she actually enjoys giving
gifts yeah i'm a giver
oh come on 100 me yeah 100
no i you kind of were yeah i was a
little bit but you were definitely a
bigger bridezilla no i don't i don't
agree you were you were a passive
aggressive bridezilla i kept telling you
oh wasn't it yes you were no passive
gross surprises i would say we don't
agree here so yeah no but password goes
on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]